alors les bio quand même vous devez vous
dire une chose auquel les duo d'acteurs
ça c'est un duo d'acteurs mais ce qui
est beaucoup plus important je vous le
dis très en passant c'est que dans ma
carrière le vrai duo keita duo qui
dépasse le duo d'acteurs qui était un
idiot de vie de carrière c'est belmondo
et moi même parce que ça fait 40 ans
dire concourent ensemble et on ne court
pas le 100 m tout seul et je suis sûr
que sans jean paul sans moi jean paul
n'aurait pas fait la même carrière et
vice versa c'est absolument évident et
ça fait pratiquement d'une émulation il
ya une concurrence mais parce que depuis
maintenant c'est un c'est un marathon qu
on a couru ensemble 40 ans 42 km presque
1 km par an et on sait au cours de notre
carrière au cours de notre vie je veux
dire indépendamment de borsalino où on
sait dépasser une fois l'hôte est en
retrait puis on sert passé puis on s'est
fait un croc en jambe et puis on s'est
jeté un coup de coude et c est
finalement au bout du marathon qui va
gagner à votre avion 42e kilomètre le
marathon moi je suis sûr qu'on va le
passer la ligne tous les deux mains dans
la mains ensemble aujourd'hui ça qui est
beau parce que ça c'est une vie jean
paul et moi un peu impression vous vous
à une petite tête à queue de sur lui la
cause de cette émission une petite quoi
une petite aide d'avant ça à cause de
cet hémisphère gauche je l'attendrai on
passera
[Musique]